serve tradition serve the father
psychologically speaking support the
tradition because you live on it there
in the old Mesopotamian story the ANU
male ish which you can which you can
read about if you're interested in the
original gods who are really badly
behaved they're like two-year-olds
in fact they're a lot like two-year-olds
they kill the primordial God AB su who's
the patriarchal God they kill him and
try to live on his corpse well that's
what we all do right because we live on
the corpse of our ancestors you could
say we live on the corpse of our culture
it's dead and that's not a great place
to live so you have to keep revivifying
it so the damn thing you know stays
active and awake you you stay on the
corpse for too long and then the devil
of or the demon of chaos comes back and
that's what happens in the Mesopotamian
story it's like don't be thinking that
you can stay on the corpse of your
ancestors for too long without
contributing to the revivification of
the system because the chaos that all of
that holds that that all of that holds
that bay will definitely come and visit
you and you see that in stories like The
Hobbit
you know hobbits they're nice they like
to eat they're kind of fat they're short
they're not very bright you know they're
hubristic they have no idea what's out
there in the broader world they're
protected if you remember by the
Striders who are the sons of great kings
who look like tramps they have nothing
but contempt for them they patrol the
borders and keep the bloody hobbits safe
but out there out there in the periphery
all hell is brewing and chaos is is is
generating and forming and that's an
archetypal story and that's why people
like that story so much because that's
exactly right like we're the hobbits and
there are we are protected from chaos by
the spirits of our dead ancestors and
we're too damn stupid to know it and we
think oh well we don't need them anymore
and that to me that's post-modernism
that's what the bloody universities are
doing with the humanities it's
absolutely appalling and we will pay for
it so no less we wake up and hopefully
we'll wake up because that would be
better than paying for it even though
being awake is rather painful